[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory over
the past couple of weeks i've posted two
harry potter fan theory compilation
style videos one focusing on the fan
theories that turned out to be true and
another focusing on the darkest theories
in today's video we're going to follow
this pattern but this time we're going
to be covering the weirdest theories
ranking them all the way up to the
weirdest theory of all i've covered a
few of these in the channel in the past
but there are also some new ones these
are going to be explained fairly
succinctly but if you want the full
version of one of these theories you can
find it on the channel's homepage which
weird harry potter theories do you guys
know do you think you can guess them
without further ado let's get started
number five george weasley is willy
wonka this extremely weird theory
connects the harry potter universe
written by jk rowling with the universe
of willy wonka and the chocolate factory
another fictional tale written by roald
dahl however this audacious theory
certainly doesn't just loosely connect
the two worlds it actually suggests that
george weasley is willy wonka the theory
but quite succinctly suggests that
george weasley after suffering the loss
of his brother fred uses the time turner
to travel back to a different era making
a new life for himself as we know george
and fred were the closest of brothers
spending every waking moment with one
another however when fred tragically
passed away george was at a bit of a
loss for what to do next rowling even
addressed the issue herself tragically
remarking that george would never get
over losing fred with his business
acumen having successfully run weasley's
wizarding wheezes and vast knowledge of
sweets george travels back in time and
starts a new life in the land of the
muggles opening willy wonka's chocolate
factory sharing his wacky inventions and
tasty sweets with the muggle world to
add to all of this george even appears
to resemble willy wonka somewhat this
theory is a stretch and i'm not
convinced but it's definitely a fun idea
and a weird one at that
4. mrs norris is filter's wife this
theory discusses argus filch hogwarts
caretaker and resident squibb as well as
his trusty feline companion mrs norris
now in the harry potter story it's made
quite clear that argus filch doesn't
love a lot of things
makes the lives of the student body
miserable and exacts what little power
he has at every opportunity however if
there's one thing he does love it's
certainly his cat mrs norris a
dust-colored feline with piercing yellow
eyes the two are never apart except for
when they've temporarily decided to
scout out different areas of the school
and they seem to have an almost
quasi-telepathic connection as they're
able to communicate in spite of the fact
that they are just well squib and cat
when mrs norris encounters students
misbehaving filch seems to show up right
away and vice versa so what could be the
explanation for their complicated
relationship in 1992 when mrs norris was
petrified by salazaren's basilisk vilch
first blamed harry potter who was
spotted right at the scene of the crime
filch is visibly more upset than we've
ever seen him before and says in front
of everyone you killed my cat i'll kill
you
i'll kill you while filch is bitter and
a bit hard to deal with sometimes he's
not usually so violent in nature and
this passion that he's exhibiting to me
suggests perhaps he knows mrs norris on
a deeper level perhaps he knows
something about her but the rest of us
don't the theory suggests this mrs
norris is filter's wife but how could a
cat be his wife well the simple answer
to that is that she's a maledictus that
is the sufferer of a blood curse which
caused her to gradually and eventually
turn in to a cat this would of course
mean that mrs norris was once a woman
and not just any woman filter's wife
again this theory is a bit of a stretch
and a weird one but it certainly caught
my attention 3. ron is dumbledore yep
you heard that right the basis for this
harry potter fan theory is that ron
weasley harry's best friend is in fact a
time travelling version of hogwarts
headmaster albus dumbledore the primary
arguments for this theory and there are
quite a few are that dumbledore seems to
know everything that harry and ron did
they're about to do
ron and dumbledore purportedly share
some physical similarities both being
described as tall then possessing a long
nose that has been broken a few times
and large hands
dumbledore also had red hair as a boy
which we know because of tom riddle's
memory dumbledore has a scar above his
left knee and ron received an injury to
his left leg possibly knee area
both men are obsessed with sweets and
introductions to both characters involve
sweets dumbledore sees himself holding
socks in the mirror of erised which
relates to ron weasley not appreciating
mrs weasley's christmas socks however
one of the main drivers behind the
theory relates to the philosopher's
stone particularly the chess match that
ron participates in in order to allow
harry to move on to the next challenge
the argument here is that the chess
match is symbolic for the war between
good and evil in the series with iran
being representative of the knight
supporting harry and dumpling acting as
king controlling everything voldemort
was able to save his memory in tom
riddle's diary was able to come back to
the real world through it so why
couldn't dumbledore achieve something
similar i'm not convinced that this
theory has much merit but it's certainly
a weird one
2. rowling is rita skeeter rita skeeter
was a british witch and infamous
journalist in the harry potter story who
specialised in writing defamation pieces
for the daily prophet she was known for
her poison pen stories which she would
base around false information and
misreported interviews writing what she
believed people would like to read
whether it was real information or not
this theory put quite succinctly is
simply that rita skeeter and jk rowling
are one in the same after being fired
from the ministry for being an
unregistered animagus a beatle skeeter
escapes to the muggle world where she
publishes her stories as fictional works
eventually adopting the pseudonym jk
rowling i like this one number one
dudley and cho theory and last but
certainly not least the weirdest theory
on the list the chadli theory that is
the theory that dudley dussley ended up
marrying ravenclaw graduate cho chang
this theory came about for a couple of
reasons but the main driver behind it is
that cho chang ended up marrying a
mughal that's canon cho chang married a
mughal furthermore we also know that
dudley dursley ends up getting married
himself but the name of his wife is
never revealed this is basically the
entire basis for the theory an unnamed
wife and an unnamed mughal we know
dudley dursley is a muggle and while
it's unusual for witches and wizards to
marry muggles it definitely still
happens often when a witch or wizard is
courting a potential muggle spouse they
fail to mention their magical abilities
which causes tension down the line when
their kids start performing magic
themselves the guilt eventually becomes
unbearable and they end up confessing
their magical status to their other half
however the years of lies are not often
entirely understood so in this respect
the relationship between cho and dudley
does sort of make sense if cho were to
have married a regular mughal then she
would have no doubt encountered the
aforementioned difficulties associated
with merkel courtship however if she
were to end up with dudley who was a
muggle there is the obvious advantage
that she would never have to hide
anything from him dudley was privy to
the magical world and there wouldn't
have been much that cho could have said
to put him off or surprise him okay now
i know what you're thinking cho and
dudley dudley was about as awful as a
young boy could be however there was a
point in dudley's life at which he hit a
bit of a crossroads the dementor attack
though the dementors weren't able to
successfully suck out dudley's soul the
attack still had a profound impact on
him as it forced him to observe the type
of person that he was after the attack
dudley certainly changed for the better
and cho well i can definitely see her
vacating the wizarding world entirely
after the death of cedric wanting an
escape from the madness of it all what
do you think is chudley cannon and
that's it for this video had you guys
heard of these theories are there
weirdest theories out there that i
missed how would you rank them leave a
comment down below until next time it
does not do to dwell on dreams forget to
live
[Music]